[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend
zusammen sportliches später dann wieder
mit Christian Otto und einer
Trainerentlassung guten Abend unsere
Themen an diesem Montag
Entsetzen über russische Raketenangriffe
in Kiew und vielen anderen ukrainischen
Städten gibt es Tote und Verletzte
Entlastungen für Gaskunden die
Expertenrunde schlägte unter anderem vor
dass der Staat im Dezember die
Abschlagszahlungen übernimmt
und die ampelparteien nach der
niedersachsenwahl Zufriedenheit bei Rot
und Grün die FDP will nach der
Wahlschlappe ihr Profil schärfen
[Musik]
der Krieg in Kiew und westlichen
ukrainischen Städten Schienen weit weg
aber seit heute morgen heulen dort
wieder die Sirenen Russlands Militär übt
nach eigenen Angaben Vergeltung für die
Explosion auf der krimbrücke am Samstag
mitten im Berufsverkehr werden Raketen
auf Kiew oder Lemberg abgefeuert es gibt
mindestens 11 Tote und mehr als 80
verletzte Jürgen Kehl berichtet
es ist 8:18 Uhr als in Kiew die ersten
Raketen einschlagen hier verfehlt eine
knapp die Fußgängerbrücke in einem Park
dort bohrt sich ein Geschoss in ein
Gebäude im Zentrum trifft es mitten im
Berufsverkehr eine Kreuzung groß und
kleine Metallsplitter fliegen Menschen
werden getroffen es gibt auch tote hier
erlebt die ersten schweren Luftangriffe
seit Juni die Regierung reagiert wütend
das ist dann harter morgen wir haben es
mit Terrorismus zu tun sie wollen Angst
und Panik verbreiten aber vergesst nie
die Ukraine gab es bevor dieser Feind
erschien und sie wird auch danach noch
existieren
überall in der Ukraine suchten Raketen
heute ihre Ziele viele Geschosse wurden
abgefangen andere schlugen ein oft ohne
Vorwarnung auch in wirpro sind die
Menschen auf dem Weg zur Arbeit dann
überraschende Detonationen erst danach
setzt der Alarm ein von einem massiven
Schlag gegen ukrainische Energie und
Militäreinrichtungen und sprach im Kreml
russlands Präsident Putin nennt das
Vergeltung für die Angriffe auf die
krimbrücke
wenn die Terrorangriffe auf unser Gebiet
weitergehen dann wird Russland hart
zurückschlagen daran sollte niemand
Zweifel haben
die U-Bahn-Schächte von Kiew bieten an
diesen Morgen wieder Schutz tausende
flüchten vor der Gefahr über Monate war
der Krieg ein Stück weit weg vom Alltag
jetzt ist er mit Macht wieder da
ein bisschen wie am 24 Februar wir
blieben in Kiew als die Invasion begann
und ich werde meine Sachen jetzt auch
nicht packen wir haben einen Platz um
uns vor all dem hier zu verstecken
neben dem Spielplatz in der Anlage ist
die Erde aufgewühlt die tödliche Gefahr
sie ist zurück in den ukrainischen
Städten
international da werden die Angriffe auf
Schärfste verurteilt Frankreichs
Präsident sieht gar eine tiefgreifende
Veränderung im Ukraine Krieg und wir
sprechen jetzt mit Katrin Eigendorf in
Kiew und für Bega in Moskau Kathrin seit
Juni gab es keinen Angriff mehr auf Kiew
heute traf es nicht nur die Hauptstadt
sondern auch andere Städte wie Lemberg
in der Westukraine was lässt sich daraus
ableiten
daraus lässt sich ableiten das Vladimir
Putin noch einmal ganz deutlich
eskalieren will in diesem Krieg das hat
eine große Symbolkraft hier in der
Ukraine man muss sich vorstellen nicht
einmal zu Anfang des Krieges haben die
Russen das Zentrum der Hauptstadt
beschossen das ist ein Prinzip jetzt das
erste Mal wirklich das Raketen direkt
hier im Zentrum eingeschlagen sind das
soll natürlich vor allem Panik unter der
Bevölkerung und Angst und Schrecken
verbreiten das tut es in gewissem Maße
auch die Menschen reagieren hier
natürlich mit großem Schreck darauf den
viele haben sich hier ja auch ein Stück
weit sicher gefühlt viele haben sind
auch aus dem Osten hierhin geflohen weil
sie dachten dass in der Hauptstadt die
Lage einfach überschaubarer ist die
Menschen erleben aber auch diese
Situation mit großer Wut das erleben wir
ja auch in den Gesprächen dass sie sagen
wir werden uns nicht einschüchtern
lassen sondern wir werden hier weiter
standhalten aber es hat eben noch mal
eine neue Qualität dass dieser Krieg
einfach deutlich eskaliert und dass es
im Prinzip in der Ukraine gar keinen Ort
mehr gibt wo Menschen sich wirklich
sicher fühlen können wir gehen von KI
auf weiter nach Moskau für über zuletzt
da wurde Russlands militärisches
Vorgehen intern von den Falken von
Hardlinern scharf kritisiert wie fallen
die Reaktionen heute aus
deutlich wohlgesonnener muss man wohl
sagen die Rhetorik des Präsidenten heute
aber eben auch die Raketenangriffe die
waren eine Machtdemonstration und die
kam bei vielen hier in Russland gut an
da ist zum Beispiel der Anführer der
Tschetschenen Ramsan kadiro auf der
heute gesagt hat er sei zu 100%
zufrieden oder der Chef der annektierten
Halbinsel Krim der gesagt hat erwerbe
seit Februar dafür dass man die Ukraine
so massiv beschießen sollte wie das
heute der Fall war und hätte man auf ihn
gehört hätte Russland seine Ziele schon
viel früher erreichen können flankiert
werden solche Aussagen dann von den
Propagandisten hier in Russland einer
zum Beispiel der schrieb er fühle sich
heute schon wie am Tag des Sieges also
diejenigen die in den letzten Tagen und
Wochen vermehrt Russlands Militär
kritisiert haben die zeigen sich heute
ziemlich zufrieden sie bejubeln
teilweise regelrecht die Härte mit der
in der Ukraine jetzt heute vorgegangen
wurde und für Präsident Putin bedeutet
das dass es ihm vorerst gelungen ist
dafür zu sorgen dass die Kritik an
Militärführung nicht auf ihn
überschwappt Filme und Katrin vielen
Dank nach Moskau und Kiew Bomben auf die
Ukraine dazu senden wir auch einen
zdf-spezial gleich hier im Anschluss und
weil in diesem Krieg gerade vieles an
vielen Stellen passierte empfehlen wir
Ihnen heute besonders unseren Liveticker
auf ZDF heute bzw in unserer App
und damit zum wohl drängendsten Problem
bei uns nämlich den Gaspreisen da hat
eine Expertenkommission jetzt Vorschläge
gemacht und zwar für Entlastungen in
zwei Schritten Schritt 1 im Dezember
soll der Staat einmalig die
Monatsrechnung für Gas und Fernwärme
übernehmen Schritt 2 ab März soll bei
der Grundversorgung ein preisdeckel
gelten um rund 96 Milliarden Euro würden
so Haushalte und Industrie bis April
2024 entlastet Winnie Hilscher berichtet
die eine Hälfte die ihr steht hat
vergangene Nacht nicht geschlafen die
Kommission hat durchgearbeitet um der
Bundesregierung heute ihre Ideen in die
Hand drücken zu können der Staat soll im
Dezember den Abschlag für private
Haushalte Zahlen dadurch wird die
Gasrechnung um eine Abschlagszahlung
entlastet das ist ein sehr pragmatisches
Vorgehen um erstmal die Kostenbelastung
für die Menschen zu dämpfen ab März
nächsten Jahres soll die sogenannte
gaspreisbremse greifen für 80 Prozent
eines geschätzten grundkontingents
werden die Preise auf 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde abgesenkt oberhalb dieser
Menge muss man dann den deutlich höheren
Marktpreis zahlen die Bremse soll bis
Frühjahr 2024 laufen für die Industrie
soll derselbe Preismechanismus gelten im
Verhältnis
70/30 eine mengenmäßige Obergrenze des
zu entlastenden Gasverbrauchs wird nicht
definiert da wir aufgrund der enormen
großen Größenunterschiede der
Unternehmen und der Bandbreite der
verbrauchten Mengen eine
diskriminierungsfreie Definition nicht
für möglich hat jetzt ist die
Bundesregierung am Zug mit hohem Druck
und hoher Energie werden wir in den
nächsten Tagen das prüfen und dann sehr
zeitnah auch da über das weitere
Verfahren berichten aber ich kann Ihnen
gleich sagen das wird jetzt einige Zeit
in Anspruch nehmen würden die
kommissionsideen so umgesetzt gehen
erste Schätzung von Einsparungen in Höhe
von 1300 Euro für Familien 800 Euro für
Paare aus kritiker bemängeln sozial
Schwache Haushalte würden zu wenig
unterstützt dem hat die Kommission nicht
widersprochen
die gaspreisbremse wurde unter
erheblichem Zeitdruck ausgearbeitet Theo
call in Berlin ist für die
Bundesregierung die Kuh damit vom Eis
also vom Eis ist sie noch nicht aber die
Kuh hat jetzt zumindest Kufen bekommen
und das Eis ist auch irgendwie gefühlt
dicker geworden das vorgeschlagene
zweistufige Verfahren schafft wenn es
denn so kommt einerseits mit dem
Dezember Geld eine erste wenn auch
überschaubare Entlastung in diesem Jahr
absehbar mega teuren energiewinter und
schafft dann vor allem in Stufe 2 einen
verlässlichen Rahmen jeder Gas und
fernwärmekunde weiß dann auf welchen
Preis er sich einstellen kann und ist
damit nicht mehr einem wild gewordenen
Markt ausgeliefert bis auf die
restlichen teuren 20% des Verbrauchs
aber die hat dann jeder in der Hand über
eigene
Energieeinsparungen die Regierung
braucht jetzt noch Zeit für die
Umsetzung es dürfte für sie aber auch
politisch schwer werden hinter die
heutigen Vorschläge der Kommission
zurückzufallen noch offen ist dagegen
die Frage ob das Ganze in der
Europäischen Union beihilfekonform ist
da könnte auf die erwähnte Kuh noch ein
Eislauf warten wenn die EU das Modell
nicht mittragen sollte Theo vielen Dank
bis hierher wir sprechen gleich noch mal
weiter über die Auswirkungen der
Niedersachsen Wahl am Tag nach eben
dieser Landtagswahl geht es in Berlin um
die Frage welche Erkenntnisse lassen
sich für die Parteien daraus ziehen
erstmal der Blick auf die Zahl
nach dem vorläufigen amtlichen Ergebnis
kommt die SPD mit Verlusten auf
33,4 Prozent noch größer das Minus bei
der CDU sie landet bei 28,1 Prozent die
Grünen können dazu gewinnen sind mit
14,5% drittstärkste Kraft die AFD legt
ebenfalls zu und kommt auf 10,9 Prozent
die FDP schafft es mit 4,7% nicht in den
Landtag und über Freude und die damit
verbundene Katerstimmung Andreas Huppert
der Tag nach Landtagswahlen ist in
Berlin meist auch der Tag der
blumenübergabe florale Danksagungen an
den Gewinner in diesem Fall an Stefan
weil seine SPD verliert zwar leicht
setzt sich allerdings vom Negativ Trend
der Bundes-SPD ab auch wenn der
Parteivorsitzende das so nicht sehen
will wir waren unterwegs der
Bundeskanzler die Parteivorsitzenden die
Bundesminister alle haben unterstützt es
ist ein Wahlsieg von Stefan weil und der
niedersächsischen SPD aber wir haben
geschlossen gekämpft und wir freuen uns
wahnsinnig über diesen Wahlsieg Freude
die bei der FDP so gar nicht aufkommen
will wie auch die Liberalen fliegen aus
dem Landtag den Grund sieht der
Parteichefin der fehlenden Anerkennung
für die Arbeit der Bundesregierung
insgesamt wir müssen schauen wie wir die
Balance aus sozialem Ausgleich
ökologischer Verantwortung und
wirtschaftlicher Vernunft so gemeinsam
justieren dass wir gemeinsam alle drei
mehr Menschen von unserem
Krisenmanagement überzeugen die Grünen
freuen sich über die großen Zugewinne
und darauf künftig Niedersachsen mit zu
regieren der Rat an die frustrierte FDP
dass wir jetzt erst recht in diesen
Zeiten der Krise und der Verunsicherung
geschlossen zusammenstehen müssen um
Erlösungen zu liefern bei der CDU
setzten sie im Wahlkampf voll auf die
Bundesregierung kann es nicht Karte das
verfing nicht und so muss der Parteichef
das schlechteste Ergebnis seit über 60
Jahren und den Verlust der
Regierungsbeteiligung kommentieren es
ist ein Rückschlag ich hätte mir das
Ergebnis anders gewünscht aber wir
lassen uns hier überhaupt nicht
entmutigen im Gegenteil es ist uns
Ansporn und Aufforderung genug jetzt
noch intensiver auch in den politischen
Themen zu arbeiten das wollen sie auch
bei der AFD die frohlockt über ihr
bestes Ergebnis in Niedersachsen
die Mandate haben sich in Niedersachsen
damit auch verdoppelt damit wird auch so
auch eine starke
Opposition in den Landtag einziehen
Niedersachsen hat gewählt und die
Auswirkungen reichen wie immer ins
politische Berlin hier wird es noch
einige Zeit brauchen bis alle Parteien
ihre endgültigen Schlüsse aus den
Ergebnissen gezogen haben
nochmal zu Till nach Berlin im Theo die
FDP kündigt an ihr Profil zu schärfen
womit müssen die ampelpartner rechnen
und was bedeutet das für die
Regierungsarbeit ich glaube die
ampelpartner dürfen damit rechnen dass
die FDP durch die erneute Wahlniederlage
zwar auch im Bund politisch an Gewicht
verloren hat aber innerhalb der Ampel
dürfte sie gleichzeitig ein höheres
Kampfgewicht entwickeln wollen die
Ansage von Christian Lindner heute war
relativ klar Profil schärfen und
Positionen deutlicher markieren das
heißt mehr FDP in der Ampel Christian
Lindner hat heute indirekt ja die
bisherige Balance zwischen den drei
Parteien in Frage gestellt es müsse auch
über mehr wirtschaftliche Vernunft
nachgedacht werden und ganz klar mehr
FDP heißt natürlich automatisch weniger
SPD oder grüne angesichts der schon mal
gemachten FDP Erfahrung dass sie damals
2013 nach einer erfolglosen
Regierungsbeteiligung komplett aus dem
Bundestag geflossen sind geflogen sind
dürfte die ampelpartner die Ansage der
Liberalen auch ernst nehmen die Grünen
jeden haben heute schon
Gesprächsbereitschaft bekundet danke für
die Einschätzung nach Berlin Theo Koll
nach den Explosionen an den nordstream
pipelands in der Ostsee ermittelt jetzt
die Bundesanwaltschaft es handle sich um
einen schweren Angriff auf die
Energieversorgung was die äußere und
innere Sicherheit Deutschlands
beeinträchtigen könne teilte die Behörde
mit aus mehreren Lex an den Röhren waren
tagelang große Mengen Gas ausgetreten
nach Recherchen des ZDF-Magazin Royal
Gerät der Präsident des Bundesamtes für
IT-Sicherheit schön Boom massiv unter
Druck Hintergrund sind
schönbrunstkontakte zu einem
umstrittenen Verein der offenbar
Verbindungen zum russischen Geheimdienst
pflegt das Bundesamt für IT-Sicherheit
ist im Bundesinnenministerium
unterstellt mehr von Diana zimmermann
im Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik ist zur Stunde noch
Arne schönboomchef am Donnerstag hätte
er den Bericht zur it-sicherheitslage
vorstellen sollen der Termin ist seit
gestern abgesagt denn alte Vorwürfe Arne
schönwurm habe zu wenig Distanz zu
Russland bekommen neues Futter gerade
jetzt davon Russland Gefahr für
Deutschlands kritische Infrastruktur
ausgeht während es aus Regierungskreisen
heißt er solle zeitnah abberufen werden
sucht die Innenministerin noch nach
Beweisen gegen den ihr unterstellten
Beamten Schönbohm das ist ein sind
ernstzunehmende Vorwürfe und die werden
wir erstmal prüfen und dann die
notwendigen Schritte auch einleiten
2012 gründete Arne schönbom den Verein
cyber-sicherheitsrat e.V der Firmen bei
ihrer IT-Sicherheit unterstützt und
Kontakte zum russischen Geheimdienst
pflegt Mitglied war dort bis heute auch
die Firma prothelion die it-software für
deutsche Firmen herstellt nach
Recherchen des zdf-magazins Royal
verbirgt sich hinter prothelion das
russische Unternehmen infotex dessen
Gründer ein ehemaliger KGB-Mann
protilion wurde heute vom Verein
cybersicherheitsrat ausgeschlossen
derweil verteidigt die Opposition Arne
Schönbohm
es wird man sicherlich genau überprüfen
müssen aber eine Schönbohm ist natürlich
ein Behördenleiter der in der
Vergangenheit exzellent gearbeitet hat
in der Vergangenheit hatte Arne schönbum
sich auch vom Verein cybersicherheit
distanziert erst vor einem Monat aber
hielt er dort eine jubiläumsrede nach
Medienberichten wurde ihm der Auftritt
vom Innenministerium genehmigt auch da
also noch viele offene Fragen
welche Rolle spielen Banken bei der
Bewältigung von Finanzkrisen unter
anderem mit dieser Frage haben sich drei
US-Ökonomen jahrelang beschäftigt und
für ihre Erkenntnisse heute den
Nobelpreis für Wirtschaft erhalten
ausgezeichnet wurden der ehemalige
US-Notenbankchef Band burninki sowie
Douglas Diamond und Philip diebig ihre
Erkenntnisse habe unsere Fähigkeit
verbessert sowohl schwere Krisen als
auch teure Rettungsaktionen zu vermeiden
so die Begründung der Jury
wir sind bei Sport beim Sport und bei
Kristin und bei der Trainerentlassung
die es jetzt mal wieder gibt in der
Bundesliga genau die war durchaus zu
erwarten der VfB Stuttgart hat sich von
Pellegrino matarazzo getrennt die
Entscheidung fiel vor gut einer Stunde
am Tag nach der Heimniederlage gegen
Spitzenreiter Union Berlin die Schwaben
Tabellen vorletzte als einziges Team
bisher ohne Sieg
diese Gesichter ließen nichts Gutes
erahnen was die Führungsetage sah aber
unterm Strich zu wenig Pellegrino
materatsus Mannschaft ist nach neuen
Spielen die einzig sieglose der Liga zu
oft gab es sie die Diskrepanz zwischen
Leistung und Ergebnis auch gestern gegen
Union der VfB mit Chancen das
entscheidende Tor aber gelangt im
Tabellenführer beim Ausblick auf das
nächste Spiel gegen Bochum ahnte Matera
zu seinen Abschied wohl voraus ich bin
sehr optimistisch dass die Mannschaft
auf das Spiel gewinnen gewinnen kann und
wird
unabhängig
wer auf der Bank sitzt materazzo war
seit Ende 2019 verantwortlich in
Stuttgart er hatte den Wiederaufstieg in
die Bundesliga und den zweimaligen
Klassenerhalt geschafft ein Nachfolger
wurde noch nicht benannt
es brodelt in der Schachszene im Fokus
zwei Großmeister seit September wirft
Weltmeister Magnus Carlsen aus Norwegen
seinem Rivalen Hans Niemann öffentlich
Betrug vor der Amerikaner soll in mehr
als 100 online Partien betrogen haben
die zweifelhafte Figur der Schachwelt
Hans Newman aktuell unterlegen in der
vierten Runde der US-Meisterschaften in
San Louis Schwaig zu jeglichen
Beschuldigungen der Skandal zwischen den
Großmeistern hält an Anfang September
verlor Schach Superstar Magnus Carlsen
online überraschend gegen niemand und
verließ das Turnier der
Untersuchungsbericht des schachportals
nie mehr Inhaber angeblich in mehr als
100 Online-Partien betrogen zwei
Vorfälle aus seiner Jugend hatte er
bereits selbst zugegeben
solange wir keine Beweise haben und der
us-schachverband oder der Weltverband
nichts unternimmt zielt es sich für die
Organisation die Spieler in Ruhe zu
lassen der Weltverband kündigt eine
Untersuchungskommission an doch dieser
Schach Thriller dürfte wohl noch vorbei
sein
gewiss nicht ja das war der Sports mit
Kristin vielen Dank es gibt ein bisschen
Regen im Süden ein paar Schauer im
Norden sonst nach Nebel Auflösung sonnig
mehr Herbstwetter gleich von Katja
horneffer um 21 Uhr empfehlen wir das
heute journal mit Christian Sievers so
viele von uns danke schönen Abend und
gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute zogen über den Süden
und den Osten Deutschlands dichtere
Wolken hinweg und die brachten auch ein
paar Spritzer Regen mit jetzt ändert
sich was beim Wetter denn hier kommt ein
Wolkenband heran das hängt an einem Tief
namens Bettina es bringt ein bisschen
Regen mit aber diese Kaltfront sieht
sehr schnell über uns hinweg schon in
der zweiten Nachthälfte erreicht sie die
Ostsee anders sieht das in
Süddeutschland aus da müssen wir uns
heute Nacht durchaus auf Regenschauer
und Gewitter einstellen hinter der
karlsfront lockern die Wolken auf es
bildet sich Nebel und dann sinken die
Temperaturen auf fünf bis zwei Grad
deutlich milder bleibt die Nacht hier im
Südwesten bei 12 bis 9 Grad und 12 Grad
das ist schon eine Höchsttemperatur von
morgen zum Beispiel im Sauerland oder
auch im Erzgebirge und dem Oberpfälzer
Wald deutlich wärmer wird es am Bodensee
oder auch am Hochrhein mit 19 vielleicht
sogar irgendwo auch 20 Grad am Vormittag
wird es hier in Norddeutschland erstmal
viel Sonnenschein geben dann aber immer
mehr Wolken das könnte auch für einige
Regen erreichen bei westnordwestwind in
der Mitte Deutschlands aber gibt es nach
Nebel viel Sonnenschein und im Süden
hält die kalt von am längsten da wird es
auch immer noch etwas regnen der
Mittwoch bringt ein goldenes
Oktoberwetter danach wird es
wechselhafter besonders in
Süddeutschland guten Abend